ahora vamos a empezar a hablar acerca de
la idea de la corriente eléctrica y la
historia de las corrientes empieza con
la idea de la carga hemos encontrado que
hay dos tipos de cargas las cargas
negativas y las cargas positivas estas
son dos cargas y sabemos que si son
cargas de distinto signo van a sentir
cierta atracción entre sí pero si
tenemos dos cargas con el mismo signo
aquí tenemos dos cargas con signo
positivo estas cargas se van a repeler
esta es la idea básica de la
electrostática y lo mismo sucede con dos
cargas negativas se van a repeler cargas
iguales se repelen y cargas distintas se
atraen esta es la idea que tenemos
acerca de las cargas pero ahora tenemos
que preguntarnos de dónde sacamos las
cargas y uno de los lugares de los que
nos gusta mucho sacar cargas es del
cobre de los cables de cobre y un átomo
de cobre se ve más o menos así tiene un
núcleo
botones y neutrones pero también tiene
electrones orbitando alrededor del
núcleo así es que vamos a dibujar las
órbitas así en estas órbitas es por
donde fluyen los electrones por afuera
del núcleo pero rodeándolo siempre y en
estas órbitas tenemos por aquí dos
electrones con su carga negativa y luego
por acá tenemos
electrones con sus cargas negativas y en
esta otra órbita también tenemos más
electrones
que están orbitando alrededor del núcleo
y bueno este es un buen dibujo de un
átomo de cobre y por cierto el símbolo
para el cobre es c/u y su número atómico
es 29 lo cual significa que hay 29
protones en el núcleo y hay 29
electrones orbitando alrededor del
núcleo y bueno aquí no dibujamos a todas
las órbitas con todos los electrones
pero si vamos a dibujar la última órbita
del cobre en la que resulta que hay
únicamente un electrón y justo este
electrón resulta ser súper fácil
quitárselo al cobre para que participe
en el proceso de conducción en una
corriente eléctrica si tenemos un pedazo
de cobre cada uno de los átomos de cobre
tiene la oportunidad de donar este
electrón el de la última órbita que está
todo solito ahora por ejemplo si nos
fijamos en un átomo de plata tiene una
configuración bastante similar
plata en su última órbita también tiene
únicamente un electrón y por eso tanto
el cobre como la plata son también los
conductores pero bueno ahora vamos a
construir un cable de cobre aquí tenemos
una especie de cable de cobre puros
átomos de cobre y ahora vamos a poner un
voltaje a través del cable por aquí
tenemos una batería una pila este es el
símbolo para una batería este es el polo
de signo menos este es el polo de signo
más y vamos a conectar la batería a este
cable de esta forma y ahora qué es lo
que está pasando en este cobre bueno
pues en este cable hay un bonche de
electrones por todos lados y todos estos
electrones están asociados con algún
átomo de cobre este cable de cobre es un
pedazo de metal neutral hay exactamente
la misma cantidad de protones que de
electrones
y estos electrones están un poco sueltos
así es que aquí cuando conectamos la
batería y ponemos una carga positiva por
acá nos vamos a encontrar en esta
situación donde la carga más atrae a las
cargas menos así es que un electrón que
tiene una carga menos se va a sentir
atraído por la carga más y se va a ir
por acá lo cual va a dejar una región
con una carga neta positiva y entonces
estos electrones se van a empezar a
mover para acá todos estos electrones se
van a mover en esta dirección y al final
un electrón va a salir de la pila se va
a mover por acá
hasta llegar a reemplazar esa carga neta
positiva que teníamos en este cable así
es que si por aquí tengo una carga
positiva porque todos los electrones
están yendo hacia la izquierda esta
batería va a soltar electrones para
contrarrestar esa carga positiva y
entonces obtenemos este movimiento de
carga negativa que fluye en esta
dirección pero ahora aquí la pregunta es
cómo medimos esto como medimos o cómo le
damos un número a todo esto que está
sucediendo por aquí ok lo que queremos
es asignarle un número asignarle una
magnitud una cantidad a esta corriente
que está fluyendo por aquí y nosotros lo
que hacemos en nuestras cabezas es
imaginarnos una barrera por acá ok nos
imaginamos esta barrera que atraviesa
por completo al cobre y ahora nosotros
vamos a imaginar que estamos parados por
aquí
y estamos muy muy atentos a lo que pasa
acá que hoy vamos a estar contando todos
los electrones que pasan esta barrera
con un cronómetro en mano también
contando el tiempo que transcurre
básicamente esto es carga negativa que
se está moviendo a un lado y nosotros
estamos contando cuánta carga negativa
atraviesa en un segundo entonces lo que
vamos a obtener es carga negativa por
segundo y es justo a eso a lo que
nosotros le llamamos corriente y es
igualito a cuando el agua corre en un
río es exactamente la misma idea bueno
ahora vamos a ver otra situación en la
que también tenemos una corriente pero
en este caso la corriente va a ser agua
bueno agua con sal digamos que tenemos
aquí un tubo lleno de agua por aquí
también vamos a poner una batería y la
vamos a conectar adentro del tubo que
estamos conectando a la batería
este es el lado positivo de la batería y
este es el lado negativo y ahora el agua
es h 2 off y el agua no conduce la carga
porque aquí no hay ni un electrón suelto
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es agregar
sal ok vamos a agregar sal sal común de
esa que le pones a tu comida y la sal
pues en realidad es el cloruro de sodio
está hecha de cloro y de sodio y por eso
la abrevia moss como n a cl porque el
cloruro de sodio es simplemente la sal
que nos comemos todos los días con
nuestra comida pero si le echamos salah
al agua la sal se disuelve y nos queda
el sodio con una carga positiva y el
cloro con una carga negativa y entonces
ya este tubo de agua le echamos al nos
queda un montón de sodio flotando por
ahí con cargas positivas pero también
con átomos de cloro bastante cerca de
los átomos de sodio con su carga
negativa
como metimos los cables adentro del tubo
con agua cuando conectemos la batería
aquí va a haber una carga positiva que
va a traer a las cargas negativas y
entonces los iones de cloro se van a
sentir atraídos por esta carga positiva
y entonces se van a mover un poquito
para acá y de este otro lado está
sucediendo lo mismo por aquí tenemos una
carga negativa proveniente de la batería
de la pila por aquí está la carga
positiva proveniente de la pila pero la
carga negativa va a traer a las cargas
positivas o sea a los iones de sodio y
al mismo tiempo va a repeler a los
cloros que tienen una carga negativa y
entonces lo que obtenemos por acá es que
las cargas positivas están fluyendo en
esta dirección y las cargas negativas
están fluyendo en esta otra y ahora cómo
le hacemos para medir esta corriente
bueno pues hacemos lo mismo que hicimos
por acá ponemos una barrera
nuestra cabeza nos paramos por acá
y nos ponemos a observar esta barrera
fijándonos en las cargas que fluyen a
través de ella y lo que vamos a
encontrar es que algunos odios van a
atravesar la barrera en esta dirección y
algunos claros también van a atravesar
la barrera pero en esta dirección aunque
hay algunos odios se mueven hacia la
derecha y algunos claros se mueven hacia
la izquierda así es que lo que tenemos
son cargas positivas moviéndose en una
dirección y cargas negativas moviéndose
en la dirección contraria y si tomamos
la suma de todas estas cargas por
ejemplo si aquí un átomo de sodio
atraviesa la barrera y un átomo de cloro
también atraviesa la barrera ahí tenemos
dos cargas que están atravesando la
barrera y bueno aquí hay unos detalles
que tenemos que ver con mucha más
profundidad pero
aquí tenemos una carga de signo positivo
moviéndose hacia un lado y una carga de
signo negativo moviéndose hacia el otro
lado entonces como se están moviendo en
direcciones opuestas y tienen signos
opuestos este movimiento cuenta igual
que si se estuvieron moviendo dos cargas
en alguna de las dos direcciones por eso
en este ejemplo también podemos decir
que la corriente
corriente es igual a la carga en
movimiento por segundo donde la carga es
justo esta suma que estábamos viendo por
acá donde aunque éstos se muevan en
direcciones contrarias como tienen
signos contrarios cuentan como si se
estuvieran moviendo dos cargas